if i have an opinion and i'm wrong
that's fine i would like to know
where i'm wrong anyway so that i'm not
like living some sort of lie right
so i'm open to learning but i say the
more um i talk about it the better i
feel because i used to especially when i
was younger and less confident i would
have you know thoughts or have and i'm
sure this goes for a lot of people you
have thoughts and have things you want
to say but you're not sure about how
people will react or whether or not
you're wrong or if you're going to
offend somebody and it's like okay maybe
better to keep that to myself
but i don't think that that makes it go
away right i don't think not saying
something makes it actually disappear
it's still out there i don't know if
it's out there in the form of energy or
if it's just trapped in you or something
but not saying things that you believe
in when you feel like you should say
them doesn't make them go away they just
get all stacked up inside you and then
you get uncomfortable